-I'm so proud
of this performance.
The growth that I've seen
through the competition
is astronomical.
Watching you come
out of your shell,
get more comfortable
on this stage,
you just walk around
with this effortless cool.
That's awesome.
When you make the song sound
like how you want them to be,
it's incredible.
Everybody's arrested in it.
And so kudos to you, man.
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here
with Chance the Rapper.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was a clip
from "The Voice."
I mean, it strikes me
that the four --
from watching it,
the four of you have
a lot of great chemistry
together --
you, Kelly, Niall, and Blake.
How do you enjoy it so far?
-I love it. Yeah.
No, we have -- we have
great chemistry.
We have just a good time
over there.
Everybody's very, like, loose.
It's very chill.
Like, even the staff
and everybody
that works on the show
is, like, just super cool.
And I'm -- I've, you know,
I've known Kelly for a while.
We've been tight.
Niall, I got to meet recently.
And he was really cool.
And Blake is there.
And...
[ Laughter ]
I really do love Blake, though.
He's very...
[ Laughter ]
He's just so unserious.
Like, you go there, and you
don't feel like you're at work.
It's like camp.
-Yes, it's very nice.
You do something
that I find very refreshing.
You will sometimes admit
that you have never
heard a song before,
especially one, you know,
I think, maybe in genres
that you didn't grow up
listening to the same way.
Which country is an example?
And I feel like
I would be embarrassed to say,
"I don't know that song."
But I really -- For me,
I enjoy it a great deal
because it gives me then
the permission to say
that I don't know all the songs.
-Yeah, no, you should have
no shame
about not knowing a song.
[ Laughter ]
Like, I'm going to be
very open every time,
and it's typically like
it's not just a song
that I've never heard before
that they have on the show.
It's like a song that none
of my friends have ever heard,
or no one that I know
has even, like, been around
that song playing in a car,
driving past.
It's, like, a completely
separate world from the song.
So I love the voice
because I get introduced
to new worlds of music.
-Yeah.
I also think it's helpful
for people
to know their worlds of music
maybe haven't permeated the
culture as much as they think.
Like, I think it's helpful
to be like, "Oh, right."
This is -- We always think
that everything we've ever heard
has been heard
by everybody else.
And it's nice to know,
"Oh, right, there's..."
I think it just
helps us know like,
"Oh, not everybody has lived
my entire existence
the same way."
-Yeah.
And I'm learning new songs,
so it's cool.
-There you go.
You learn new songs, as well,
which is really nice.
You auditioned --
Is this a true story?
When you were in high school,
you auditioned
for the slam team.
-I did.
-So, that's slam poetry? Yes?
-Yeah, that's slam poetry.
Slam poetry, for y'all
who don't know,
it's the hyper athletic
form of poetry.
[ Laughter ]
A lot more hand movement.
But I was into slam poetry
when I was growing up.
That was, like, my first foray
into performing arts.
And -- That's not true.
I danced before that.
But in, like, making stuff --
-Whoo!
-Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
In the making my own pieces,
I was really interested
in poetry.
And so, funny enough, that's,
like, one of the only things
I've ever auditioned for.
-And did you get it?
-No. It's so weird.
-What? It is.
[ Laughter ]
-It's so weird.
So it's my high school
slam team,
and they're like,
"Hey, in order to get
on the slam team this year,
we're hosting auditions.
We're gonna do
an after-school open mic.
And based on your performances
and your content,
we're deciding who's gonna
be on the slam team.
And I did not make it
on the slam team.
But who did make it
on the slam team,
weirdly enough, was Vic Mensa,
another artist from Chicago.
Um, and -- but weirdly enough,
as some of you guys didn't clap,
because, you know,
me and Vic didn't go
to the same high school,
so him getting onto
the slam team...
[ Laughter ]
...was more of, like,
a symbolic win
and, like, a huge
symbolic loss for me.
-So not only did
they not pick you,
they went outside
to other schools?
-Another school, and said,
"This guy -- This guy is good."
[ Laughter ]
And so, needless to say,
I never auditioned
for another thing,
because that level of failure
was crazy.
[ Laughter ]
And -- And -- But me and Vic
ended up going on
to become best friends.
We recorded a lot
of great music together,
stuff that's on acid rap,
and now have
a festival together --
the Black Star Line Festival.
-Alright.
Well, it all worked out then.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I was lucky enough to ask
a fellow Chicagoan, Common,
a question last time
he was here,
that Common's grandmother and
your grandmother were friends.
-Yeah!
He talked about it on the show?
-He talked about it on the show
that you...
-That's so cool.
-...young pre-fame Chance,
-Tony Jizzle.
-Uh, Tony Jizzle.
[ Laughter ]
I can't believe
you made Common's grandmother --
your grandmother
made Common's grandmother
say to Common, "Tony Jizzle
wants to talk to you."
-"Talk to Tony Jizzle"
-Yeah. But he did.
He got on the phone with you.
-He did.
So he didn't actually
get on the phone with me.
He left
an answering machine message,
because I was too busy that day.
I was in high school.
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
-And when he called me,
I was obviously busy.
So he left a voicemail message.
And I remember,
it was such a big deal.
My homey Reece, my homey Justin
were there.
We were walking down
the street,
and I was, like, going through
my answering-machine messages.
And I had --
And it was really common.
And he was like, "Man, just
keep doing what you're doing.
Just keep trying."
He's very poetic.
He doesn't slam poetry,
but he, like, lay-up poetries,
because it's smooth.
And like, he like --
But he gave me some --
[ Laughter ]
He gave me inspi---
-Finger-roll poetry.
-Yeah, it's like...
[ Laughter ]
But he gave me
some really inspiring words.
And I just remember,
I was really bummed out
because I couldn't figure out
how to call him back,
'cause I was gonna try
and, like, pitch him
on signing me or something.
I don't know.
But, yeah, eventually,
I met him in real life,
and I was like, you know,
"Common,
obviously, I'm a huge fan.
You're a legend.
You're -- You know,
obviously, Common is Common.
And I just want to tell you
that when I was a kid,
your grandmother had you
call my phone
and leave
an answering-machine message."
He was like, "Tony Jizzle?!"
[ Laughter ]
That part --
That part is not true.
I'm doing it up.
But he did know
it was me, though.
-That's right. That's wonderful.
And I do think
it's a reminder to all of us,
like, when you get --
when a grandmother reaches out
to your grandmother
and says,
"You have to call,"
like, always do it,
because you never know
when that --
because otherwise
you're walking up to him
being like,
"You wouldn't call me."
[ Laughter ]
-But you also --
Your dad was involved
in Chicago politics,
and so you got to know --
or not know,
but you got to meet --
-I got to meet Obama
when I was a little, little boy.
-Gotcha.
-Eighth grade.
It was very cool.
And then I got to meet him
after I got famous, too.
-That's pretty good.
Did you tell him
when you were a young man
that you wanted to be a rapper
one day?
-I did.
And he famously said --
He replied, "Word."
[ Laughter ]
They don't believe in us, man.
Don't believe in us.
It was it was cool, though.
And then he ended up putting me
on, like, a playlist,
like, after when I put out
some music
and I was older
and I had a new name.
He put me on the playlist.
-Well, well-deserved.
-Thank you.
-Let me point out,
well deserved.
He knows how to put together
a playlist,
among other things.
Hey, what a delight
to have you here.
Thanks so much.
Congratulations
on the anniversary.
-I'm so glad.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you, Chance.
Chance the Rapper.
"The Voice" airs Mondays
at 8:00 on NBC.
For more information
on the 10th anniversary
of "Acid Rap"
and upcoming shows,
go to chancestuff.com.
We'll be right back.